OK.
We're going to get going.
Welcome everybody.
It is wonderful to see so
many friendly faces, people
that I know, many members of
these project teams, all here
because of a great
deal of work that's
happened over the last
year or 18 months.
My name is Erin Driver-Linn.
We have a speaker
series in HILT that we
try to do once a semester.
We think of this
speaker series as a way
to bring in members
of our community,
or people from outside, who are
scholars doing their own work
and who are applying something
in their scholarship,
or loosely related
to their scholarship,
to teaching and
learning improvement.
And this time around,
we were thinking
we should maybe have a
separate event for curriculum
mapping instead of doing
our usual speaker series,
where we'd feature one person.
Instead, we said, why not?
This kind of fits in our
speaker series theme.
But how in the
world are we going
to have all of these people
speak and be able to get
through all of these ideas?
So we feel-- with a little
bit of misgivings, today, I'm
going to be emceeing and walking
through a lot of projects that
don't represent my
thinking or my work at all,
and instead represent the
fine ideas of these people,
and hope that I
can get most of it
right-- that we can
get a kind of overview.
And then we're going to pull out
a couple of different projects
for a little bit
of a deeper dive.
Before we go into each of
these individual projects,
there's a couple of other
things that I want to do.
So I want to give a little
bit of organizational context
and the story of
how we came to begin
using this term,
"curriculum mapping"
and begin putting all of
these projects together.
And then we're going
to really focus
for a while on the
data infrastructure
and the kind of tools and ways
of thinking and data sources
that we think will help amplify
all of these projects moving
forward, and hopefully
catalyze many of you
to be thinking of other
sorts of curriculum mapping
kinds of work.
And for that part
of today's agenda,
Dustin is going to run
through some of the many tools
that he's been working on.
And then we hope to have
quite a bit of time for Q&A.
One of the things that I think
is really important for us
to try to get to in the
question and answer time
is what are we-- what's
the upshot of all of this?
How do we pull the
picture together
with all of these
different kinds of projects
and understand from a
broader perspective where
the university ought
to be around making
the curriculum
visible for students,
for faculty, and
for administrators?
And then, finally, we'll
have a reception where people
can talk with one another.
And if you find that there's
something particularly
interesting about one of
these projects, or a question
that you have that you'll
be able to identify
the people who-- you'll see
their faces on the screen,
or you may see them up here.
And go up and talk
with them and see
if there's some way that there
is an action item coming out
of the work that you
can see in your roles
with members of these teams.
So the story of
curriculum mapping.
Overheard in the yard in 2016.
I don't even know why
it was required to take
a course before this one.
It didn't really
help prepare me.
I asked the professor,
and he said,
he didn't really know either.
He said, he was told it should
be listed as a pre-req when
he started here and was asked to
take over teaching the course.
[LAUGHING]
So this is slightly outside
of the yard, where I heard it.
And this is a paraphrase.
I didn't actually
take the quote down.
But the three parts
of this I overheard,
which was a student
saying he didn't
understand why he was
having to take something
as a prerequisite.
And saying that the
professor didn't know either.
And then the inherited
part that the professor
inherited the course.
And so all of these
things, I think,
are related to how
a curriculum evolves
and how it begins
to-- it may have
started with an intentional
plan, within a department, say.
And then it evolves over time
in a way that it's lost--
we've lost the thread,
so that students
and faculty and decision
makers who are administrators
in the department
no longer know why
these sequences go together,
why courses go together.
And we certainly don't
have an insight, often,
into the kinds of things
that are being taught
in someone else's
course that may
have a title even very similar
to the one that we're teaching.
Hearing this and
similar kinds of things,
I became more
attuned to the work
that other people were
doing that seemed like it
was addressing this kind of--
a set of problems.
And then I was at
a reception at MIT.
And I met a faculty
member there named
Karen Willcox who is a professor
of aeronautical engineering.
And she was working with
a bunch of MIT students
to really carefully
map their curriculum.
So that got me super excited.
And we brought Karen over for
a speaker series, was it--
three speaker series ago.
And I thought this
is our solution.
Karen's architecture and
what she's working on,
we can just import it here.
And so we tried to do that.
And it didn't work,
because we're Harvard.
And we're not like MIT.
And I should have known that.
Of course, I do know that.
But we instead, I
think, have to do it
a different way,
which is to identify
all of the different kinds of
curricular mapping exercises,
and then think about
how do they individually
sum up to something that
we can take and think
about systematic ways of making
the curriculum more visible.
So part of what we
were doing initially
was having a small working
group that got together.
And then the working
group began to expand.
And it has continued to expand,
and players in this picture
have come in and out,
and there are probably
slots there that we could
put different faces.
And then at different
times when we've
tried to explain how these
curriculum mapping projects
may or may not go together--
I've bucketed them.
And these are two buckets--
ways that we've
tried to bucket them.
It's imperfect, but we're
going to try to follow along
a little bit as a way to give
a structure to all of these 10
projects.
So projects addressing
content that's
taught across Harvard
schools and projects
addressing student
learning and enrollment
patterns within subjects is the
way we're talking about this.
So we have this
working group and then
we have an organization that
holds many organizations
in the Office of the
President and Provost.
And our role, within
the Vice Provost
for Advances in
Learning umbrella
is to try to help
the schools who
are working on their own
teaching and learning efforts.
And we do so in
different ways in
these different organizations.
So HILT, our role--
I'll say a little bit more
about HILT in a minute,
but we primarily do grant
making and convening.
And HarvardX, as you know, is
really an amazing organization
for experimentation in
curriculum design, pedagogy,
and even understanding new
ways that courses and content
can be sequenced, but
mostly in the online space.
And VPAL Research,
headed by Dustin,
is an organization
that draws on the data
structures from
residential education
and from online education to
help to build tools and build
a research program that
can help us understand
teaching and learning
improvements more broadly.
Out of VPAL Research came
another organization,
DART, Digital Assets
for Reuse and Teaching.
And we think DART could actually
be considered a curriculum
mapping project, which is a
little confusing, because it's
an organization, and it's
part of another organization.
But it's also one of
these curricular mapping
projects, which we'll
say a little bit
more about in a minute.
So HILT's mission is catalyzing
innovation and excellence
in learning and teaching and,
as I said, largely through grant
making and convening.
And I just wanted to
put up the team pictures
today, because I
hope you will be
able to meet your colleagues
during the reception.
And because we have three
new members of our team.
We have Allison Pingree,
we have Cassie--
Cassie McGrath, and we have
Zach Wang, who started today.
[LAUGHING]
Yay!
Great to start on a day when
we have an event like this one.
Each of the colleagues
in HILT, and that
includes Melissa Godet
and Jaime Goldstein.
Where's Jaime?
Oh, right there.
And Bea Frain, have
been helping the overall
with HILT. But I want to just
say, in particular, that Jaime
has been taking a leadership
role in trying to have all
of these curricular
mapping projects
have a kind of coherence and
get the working groups together
and have us work together.
And so we'll send another
thank you your way later,
but all of their goals
relate to the next steps
for the university, as we
think through what to do
with these various projects.
So shifting from the
organizational context
and the story behind us
putting all of these projects
together--
I like to think of
Dustin as a jump starter.
And I actually have the
visual of those, like,
clamps you put on
the dead battery--
like, you open the hood
and you put the clamps
on the dead battery, and
you give the jump start.
And so early on
when we were talking
about these curricular
mapping ideas,
and he met Karen
Willcox, and he was like,
I can do this in
the gov department.
I can build something.
And it seemed like the
next week there was
something for us to look at.
And he began to iterate.
And of course, that
early view moved
into a number of
different directions
that he's going to talk about.
But I thought because
he's the jump starter
I would use the enrollment view
project as a way to orient you
to these slides and the
way we're going to try
to talk through these projects.
So you see on the
bottom of these slides--
I think I have a pointer
here, this line--
and it represents a rough
progression of project phases.
So identifying
what it is you want
to do, collecting data,
analyzing it, exploring
solutions, testing them,
making some short-term changes,
iterating, getting more
testing, and, then,
eventually getting to
where we're expanding
and doing something
that's more systematic.
And what we've tried
to do is put in red
where we think these
projects are now.
One could argue
with it, but that's
where we-- what
we've tried to do.
And with each of
these projects we'll
introduce the set
of questions that
motivate the work and
the key constituencies.
So here, what are the student
patterns of course choice
within the gov department?
How do they change for
subgroups of students?
What are the relationships
between courses?
What are the learning
objectives for each course?
And then the key
constituencies--
undergraduate students
and the gov department.
Where do we want to be with
this project one year from now?
All FAS departments
actively using
a version of enrollment view.
Faculty discovering
their nearest neighbor.
And here we get to another
curricular mapping project,
Andrew Ho who will talk
about this in a minute.
The nearest neighbor
project has now
sort of integrated a little
bit with the enrollment view
project.
And that's where we
hope these things go,
as we begin to think of the
synergies and the integrations.
And then the hope from
the particular point
of view of this project
for curriculum mapping
at Harvard, broadly--
surface enrollment
patterns within departments
and across departments,
teaching your class,
mindful of other classes
that your students are in.
And there is a
pretty picture here.
And I'm not going to talk
about the pretty picture
because Dustin is going to talk
about the pretty picture now.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Erin, for
the introduction.
If I'm a jump
starter, I hope I'm
on the positive
side of the lead.
So my name's Dustin Tingley.
I'm a professor of government
and I'm also the Faculty
Director of VPAL Research.
This is a little bit of an
explanation of what we do.
And we have a really fortunate
role in the university
to straddle the online space
and working with our partners
in HarvardX, but
also residential.
And that gives us
an opportunity to be
aware of a variety of different
approaches to education,
a variety of different
types of data
streams that come out
of those approaches,
and really trying to
leverage insights that
come from both sides.
How do we help HarvardX
with what we learn
from the residential space?
And how do we enhance the
residential space, given
what we know from HarvardX?
I should say that this is
framed around VPAL Research,
but in doing so, we
definitely work very closely
with the folks over in HUIT
who control a lot of the data
systems and whatnot.
And they're a huge partner.
And I'm just really glad
to see some folks from HUIT
here today.
So what I'm going to do briefly
is to just layout that--
Harvard has this
huge, rich array
of different sources
of data that touch
on teaching and learning,
ranging from the Student
Information System, the course
catalog, the Canvas Learning
Management System-- this is
where you're running a course.
You have a course website.
This is where you go
to find a syllabus,
or engage in a discussion forum,
or find readings, et cetera.
We have student evaluation data.
I'm not going to talk
about any of that.
But that's a really
rich source of data.
We have a whole range of
Harvard YouTube channels.
So these are official
And there's a lot of
great content on it.
We have HarvardX.
And then we have a whole layer
of really just being mindful
of who should get access to
what data and what information.
I don't need to get access
to all of the information
that someone in institutional
research can get access to.
I don't need that.
And so we're very mindful of
thinking through authentication
and just permissions.
And here, HarvardKey,
which has really
come online in a major way
in the past couple of years
has been really helpful
for a variety of projects.
So the Student Information
System-- many of you
might think about this as
something like my.Harvard.
And this is a place
where students go.
It's where they're going to
do different registration
operations, et cetera.
And this is a--
not just an interface for
students and for faculty
and for staff, but it also has
a big data layer behind it,
right.
And that data layer
is very valuable.
I'll showcase a
couple of the ways
that we've been
thinking about it.
And it's not just on
projects that I've worked on,
but there's also been
other projects that
have benefited
from the nice work
that HUIT has put
into architecting
the kind of database
back end for my.Harvard.
So one example of this
is the enrollment view.
So this is literally just asking
a question of what courses--
if someone has taken a
course in the gov department,
what were the other courses
that they took, right?
What sequence of
courses did they take?
Or to get to Andrew
Ho's brilliant idea
about nearest neighbors,
if I'm teaching
a course, what are the other
courses that my students are
enrolled in?
That's actually really
valuable information.
What are they experiencing as
they are going through what
I want them to experience?
And we'll talk a little bit
more about nearest neighbor
in a second.
And you can think
about these things.
So this is going to be for
the physics department.
So we've been working
with them, as well.
So I'm teaching a class.
There are these other classes
that students are enrolled in.
You can even see the second
order nearest neighbor.
This is like not your
neighbor, but the neighbor
down the street, right.
And what classes that
overlap are happening there.
Or what's the sequence of
classes that people are taking?
What have people
taken before my class?
And what do people statistically
tend to take afterwards?
And then, finally,
there's always
questions about, like, are
there trends in enrollment
that we within a department
administratively look at.
And so this is
something that we will
be rolling out to a whole
range of FAS departments.
I'm working quite
closely with Harvard's
institutional research and
our friends over in HUIT
to be able to do.
Another project was just saying,
let's bring together easy ways
to just search
course descriptions.
And this was an effort that
arose out of our friends
in the Safra Center
for Ethics just wanting
to know, where are
people teaching ethics?
And so we are able to, again,
work with folks at HUIT to be
able to import all of the course
description information that we
could get, also grab some
of that information for some
of the other schools that aren't
on my.Harvard and put it in one
place, make it searchable,
and do all sorts of--
be able to make nice
plots of different things.
A challenge of-- it's
not really a challenge.
It's just sort of a
reality, is that we
are a little bit spread out
in terms of our data systems.
And that's OK.
That's changing.
This is a little bit of
a moving target, as well.
This is not fixed in stone.
It might change in the coming
months and year and whatnot.
But there are some different
data systems out there.
We have been working a lot
with the my.Harvard back end.
But there are some
others out there.
And one of the
things that we do is
to try to think about
common underlying things
so that even if people have
different data systems,
we can bring that data together
and have it be meaningful to be
co-located together.
A final piece that really,
I think, highlights
the opportunities
for merging data
from a whole
variety of systems--
this is the syllabus
exploration tool.
This is something that is now
available to anyone in FAS.
You can go to a
syllabus.hmdc.harvard.edu,
and you can search across
most of the syllabi that
are used in the FAS.
OK.
So how do we do that?
So what's one thing
that you're supposed
to do if you're an instructor
on your Canvas site?
What's one thing that
you're supposed to do?
What should you do?
You should post your syllabus.
OK.
Now, you are going to do that
in a variety of different ways
because I can see that data.
There are particular ways
we prefer you to do it,
but whatever, we'll
figure it out.
And so what we did is we--
working very closely
with Dean Mike Smith--
went out and got
syllabi from across all
of these different
courses, took those files,
extracted the text
from them, and then
essentially made it
searchable, right.
So you can go in, and you
can find people's syllabi,
and actually get the actual
file that was their syllabus.
And think of the syllabi
as being essentially
like a curated reading list.
So if you're writing
a senior thesis,
and you're interested
in some topic,
well, one thing you could do is
you could go to Google and type
in that topic.
And then, who knows where
you're going, right?
But why not, if you
could, in a sense,
like Google the inside of some
of the most brilliant people's
minds in the world.
And see what they would suggest
reading, given your topic.
That would be a much
greater opportunity.
So the syllabus project
took information
from Canvas, the learning
management system on the one
hand, brought it together
with some other information
from the operational data
storage system in HUIT,
and put those things together.
And now we have this
as a product for FAS.
And furthermore, it's
been written in a way
that we hope some of our
friends from other schools
would be interested
in joining the party.
So at some point, this
could be something
like syllabus.harvard.edu
and really scale
across the institution.
That's a dream right now,
but I'm a jump starter.
So I'll leave it there.
All right.
So now, we're going to
romp through a series
of these projects.
And as we do, I'm hoping that
when we look at the project
teams, that members
of those project teams
will stand up and turn around,
so that everyone else can
see them.
So that when we
have the reception
they know who to
go and talk with.
Oh, this was the
little exhibit to say
we're not going to talk
about enrollment view
because we've already talked
about enrollment view.
And then when we get to the
physics learning outcomes,
we're going to have
a little deeper dive
with that particular project.
But we're going to start
with common competencies
for a master's redesign.
So Matt Miller, Becca Miller--
No relation.
[LAUGHING]
Sitting on opposite
sides of the room,
but working very closely
with their colleagues,
helped the School of
Education get to a place
where, in May, they
voted successfully
on a curricular reform
for the master's programs
at the school.
And I think it
took a lot of work
and a lot of thinking
to get there.
And I want us to just imagine
some of the challenges here,
like a master's student
who comes to the Ed School
could choose one of
13 different tracks.
There are about 700 that
come from master's programs
and you're just on
campus for one year.
Now, how do you think
about a professional school
in education and imagine each
of those different tracks
and educating them to have the
competencies to go out and do
what they need to do in
a bunch of different ways
in a bunch of different
kinds of professions?
So at the Ed School, people--
the students, as I
understand it, they come in
and it's not like undergraduates
coming into a core program
and learning what it is
that they want to do.
They're professional students.
They have some ideas about
what they want to do.
But they come from all
different kinds of backgrounds.
And some people want
to be data scientists,
and some people want
to be policy makers,
to be educators,
and some people want
to be superintendents.
And there's different ways
that you might come in and want
to use a master's program.
So part of the
curriculum redesign
was a set of
discussions about what
are the core competencies
that faculty can agree on
should cross all of these.
But how can we, now,
using technology,
using what we understand
about pedagogy,
actually think through how to
deliver that in a personalized,
individualized way
for students who
come from different
backgrounds and need
to go into different places.
So it's a tough set of problems.
And I'm focusing
on it a little bit
because I think it's
a set of problems
that many of our
schools struggle with,
many of the professional
schools, in particular.
You have people
who are coming in,
and all of these
different backgrounds,
and they need to go out
in these different ways.
But you have to,
as a school, say
what are these
core competencies,
and how might we deliver
education flexibly,
in individualized ways, to
be able to get them through
and learn from the time
while they're on campus,
which isn't very long.
So how do we allow
learners flexibility
as they're attaining the same
professional competencies,
leverage technology and data to
support diverse adult learners,
prepare professionals for an
evolving career in education?
And the key constituents here
are master's degree students,
faculty, staff, and alumni.
And you can see where
they see this process.
Goals by next year--
launch a first foundational
course, How People Learn.
And this is, I think, a
really remarkable experiment.
The How People Learn
course, which I think
is a collaboration with
other people in VPAL,
and is being built right now
as an individualized, flexible
program.
And it relates to
all of our interests.
And many people here
have an interest
in what are pre-matriculation
materials that
could be provided before
people even get on campus.
So in addition, they're thinking
about, as part of a curriculum
mapping project,
learner profiles.
How individual students can
identify where they want to go,
what their course
progression looks
like, and the kinds
of things that they
may be taking on
in incompetencies
as they go through the program.
How that, as a data source,
might relate to other data
sources in the school, allowing
for more visibility, as you're
going rapidly through
a set of courses.
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard--
collaborative exploration
and innovation
around personalized,
competency-based, professional
education.
So nearest neighbors,
also an Ed School project.
Andrew Ho.
This was Andrew's
brainchild, I believe partly
as GSE faculty member, partly
as faculty chair of the VPAL
Research Committee.
And some of the
questions are who
are the students that
are in your class, what
other classes are they taking?
And what should I know from
the faculty members who
are teaching those classes
about what they are doing
in their classroom that I can
leverage and optimize when
I'm teaching in my classroom.
How can we make it pretty
easy and quick for people
to learn from one another?
If you begin to nurture these
neighborhoods of instructors,
can we call--
can we create some coherency--
even more coherency and maybe
some ways of teaching that make
better use of people's time?
So at the moment, this is
being used by HGSE faculty,
but next year, your school.
So this, like some of the
other projects that Dustin
was talking about,
it wouldn't be
that hard to adapt and to
move into different schools
and different kinds of programs.
So it's in a phase
of user testing.
Can people read
the print on this?
Yes.
All right.
So you can see that the way
this visual works is you've
got the course in the
center, which is red,
being your course.
And you can see, in
the previous semester,
what percentage of your students
were in these other classes,
and what percentage in
the current semester
were in these other classes.
And you can also begin to use
this data to project forward,
to predict what percentage
might be in other classes.
And by June, full integration
of this nearest neighbors
visual data set with VPAL
instructor tools, emails
to instructors answering,
"Who's your nearest neighbor?"
And "What do good neighbors
do for each other?"
That sounds sort
of Mr. Rogers like.
[LAUGHING]
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard,
clear focus on the
question, whose question
are we answering?
Yes, I agree.
And how actionable
is the answer?
OK.
Science advising-- Logan.
Logan is Director
of Science Education
and, as you can see there,
has other titles, as well--
is an amazing instructor.
And the questions, here, are
which structures and systems
will nurture and support
undergraduate research?
How do we meaningfully
connect undergraduate research
to the curricular experience?
Which skills and
competencies should we
be fostering and assessing from
students research experience?
Science concentration advisors
are a key constituency group,
undergraduate students,
and research mentors.
And from what I
understand, as you
began to think about this work
and this project and making
research experience
for undergraduates
more visible to
science advisors,
you maybe worked with Harvard
College Institutional Research,
got some data, and saw that 90%
of undergraduates in the life
sciences have done some
sort of research experience
during their time at Harvard.
And in the largest undergraduate
biology concentrations,
70% of undergraduate
research is done not at FAS,
but at the School of Public
Health, the medical school,
and affiliated hospitals.
The kinds of things
that you wouldn't
know, unless you're
making these sorts of data
accessible and visible, and then
into the awareness of science
advisors.
So this, of course,
raises questions, as well,
about the oversight,
and if we're
capitalizing on
undergraduate research work
that's being already done
in the best possible way.
Goals by June 2019--
a mix of top down and
bottom up data collection
around undergraduate
research in science,
making data
accessible and useful
to inform advising about
research and courses.
And hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard-- students
make more informed decisions
about the research,
make more connections
between research
and the rest of the curriculum.
I don't know how we
do that, but I think
it's incredibly important.
And we hear all the time,
how important that is.
How do these
research experiences
integrate with the
rest of the curriculum?
So I'm now going to
step down and let
us have a little
break from my droning
on and hear a little bit more
depth from Logan and Louis
about this last in this category
of the curriculum mapping
projects.
So in the physics
department, where Louis and I
are both faculty
members, we started
to get interested in questions
about departmental level
learning objectives
and department
level learning outcomes.
So a little bit of
history behind this.
So Chris Stubbs, who recently
served a term as interim chair
and previously had been chair
of the physics department,
has long been
interested in improving
undergraduate education.
When he was the
department chair,
he brought Carl Wieman to
campus to talk to faculty
about creating learning
objectives for their courses
and helping faculty to try
to define, what do you really
want them to learn when they
take electricity and magnetism
or quantum mechanics or whatever
that individual course is?
And Chris, at the time, said,
OK, I'm department chair.
I can just wave my magic wand
and make everyone make learning
objectives for their courses.
And of course, we
know that didn't work.
[LAUGHING]
But Chris realized that this
idea of actually defining
learning objectives is
a very powerful notion--
that you can really
articulate what
it means to learn the content
and skills and concepts
in a course.
And a few years later, when
Chris was serving a term
as interim chair
of the department,
he wondered, is there anything
I can do, one semester as chair,
that could have a lasting impact
on undergraduate education
in the department?
And he turned to
Louis Deslaurier
who is Director of Science
Teaching and Learning in FAS,
and also a senior preceptor
in our department.
And Louis is one of the great
experts in science education,
here.
And Louis immediately
said, well,
there is something that
no one else is doing,
which is actually looking
at the department level
at learning objectives.
What, as a department,
are we actually teaching
our physics undergraduates?
And Louis said, no one's doing
this at other institutions
because they think
it's just too hard.
OK.
They think that
logistically trying
to get all of the students
and trying to get faculty
to agree about what the
department learning objectives
are-- these will
be too challenging.
So Chris said, OK, let's do it.
[LAUGHING]
And so this project was launched
with some specially arranged
help from HILT. At
the HILT conference
where-- those of
you who were there--
remember that Chris was
presented as a guinea pig,
if you will, with an opportunity
for the entire HILT conference
to weigh in on what Chris
ought to do in his one
semester as interim chair to
improve teaching and learning
in the department.
And one of the options was
create a departmental level
assessment to assess teaching
and learning in the department.
And Lo and behold, that was
one of the recommendations.
So with that
ringing endorsement,
one of the curriculum mapping
projects that was started
was this very project.
So we wanted to
know, how do we know
if the department, as
a whole, is actually
successful in teaching
the concepts and skills
that we think are important
for undergraduate success
in physics and future success
as they go into their careers,
or graduate schools?
How do we actually
engage faculty
in thinking about departmental
level learning goals?
As you can imagine, that
can be a contentious issue.
And how do we increase
our students' awareness
about what they know and
what they don't know?
So we're looking here both at
the undergraduate concentrators
and at the faculty to try
to understand this better.
So our goals by
June of next year
is that we'll have, we
hope, a system in place
where all of our
undergraduate concentrators
are assessed twice.
First around of the end of
their second year and again
in their fourth year.
That we have student level
and departmental level
interventions in response
to these results and that
we can actually validate
the assessment itself.
This is a little snapshot
of part of the assessment,
which is something that we think
is a very simple question--
conceptual question in
quantum mechanics about
the eigenfunction of a
Schroedinger equation
for a semi infinite's--
well, anyway, I won't go on.
[LAUGHING]
And our hopes for
curricular mapping
are that in the future
when we have our curricular
reforms in the
physics department,
we can actually
target those reforms
at places where we know
that we need to focus,
in terms of outcomes.
And then we can actually
assess those changes
on a department level.
And finally, we hope that
our students can actually
be more confident
and can articulate
what the skills are
that they've learned
as undergraduate
concentrators in physics.
And now, I will turn
this over to Louis,
who understands this all
much more deeply than I do,
to explain a little bit
more about the details
of this project.
OK.
So a little bit about
the design here.
So first, the test is made up of
a broad range of topics, right.
We want to make sure that
faculty and students feel
like it's quite
representative of what
it means to be a physicist, by
the end of your fourth year.
So I made sure to see as many
colleagues and department
as possible to get their input.
And I asked them,
what do you think
are the most important skills,
most important concepts,
that your students should
master by the time they get out
of the program?
And I got a lot of
feedback, obviously.
But one thing that was common--
feedback that was
common to everyone
was about they wanted to make
sure that this assessment did
not look just like a final exam
at the end of a course, which
in physics often times involve
end of the chapter, end
of the textbook problems.
So they didn't want the
exam to look like that.
And that's why if you
look at the assessment,
we have some practical lab
physics questions on there.
We have even some
open-ended questions.
So it really does
feel quite different.
But most importantly, I wanted
to make sure that it only
had conceptual questions.
And it's well known, now,
in science education,
that the retention of concepts
is quite robust over time
when you compare that
to retention of facts--
facts like procedures,
steps that you
need to solve an
equation or something.
That's just forgotten almost in
that the same rate as a phone
number or someone's name, right.
In fact, several years
ago, we published something
where we looked at how students
retain quantum mechanics
concepts.
At the end of their first
quantum mechanics course,
students were given
a test of learning.
And the test of
learning comprised
deeply conceptual questions
as well as procedures.
Right.
So a year and a half
later, we gave them
the same test of
learning, and we made sure
that they had no exposure to
quantum mechanics in between.
And interestingly, the concept
was retained almost at 100%.
OK.
The deeply conceptual
ideas, but the facts,
procedures, not
surprisingly, they
had decayed almost to
zero-- to noise level.
So that's why I
wanted to make sure
that the feedback that
this test would give us,
faculty and students,
was meaningful.
So in fact, you'll see when I
talk about student interviews,
here, not a single student
said, oh, I learned this before,
but I think I did not answer
it correctly because I forgot.
Because people know
intuitively these questions.
If you just don't know how
to answer them a year later,
that's because you didn't
learn it in the first place.
So that's a very important
part of the design.
So I tried to use as many
validated questions as
possible.
I called my colleagues
at other universities,
but we can only use a few.
So this assessment will have
to be validated this year.
So let's talk about
results a little bit.
Students did not perform
as well as they hoped.
So with an average of
46%, and the distribution
was pretty wide.
So now, you should know, if
you ask is this test too hard?
Well, I started to give
it to graduate students,
so they score a lot higher,
but still not that great.
Much worse than they would like.
And I just got the green light,
I think, in the last faculty
meeting that we had, to start
giving it to my colleagues.
[LAUGHING]
Anyway, it'll be
anonymous, right?
I'll say, I'm the only
one that has the key.
So I'll be able to get
favors from people.
[LAUGHING]
So here's what's really
interesting, here, everyone--
no exception-- expected
to get an A on this test,
and they were all
very disappointed.
So that's a bit of
a downer, right?
Very disappointed, in fact.
To the point where I
was quite concerned
with a few first students.
But I interviewed every student.
So I made them one-on-one.
And part of the script at the
beginning for the interview
was about their perception
of fairness for the test.
I asked them, is the test
fair in your opinion?
And I just let them talk.
Then, after that, I provide
them with a definition we
can both agree on for fairness.
The definition I gave
them is that I said,
let's imagine that for example
the questions on quantum
mechanics for this test--
let's say that you had
been asked those questions
at the end of your course where
you learned quantum mechanics.
Would it be fair for the
instructor in the course
to expect you to get all
these questions right?
And without exception,
students said, yes, absolutely.
At the end of a course
in quantum mechanics,
I should get those quantum
mechanics questions right.
So they did feel like
the test was fair.
So it was very
disappointed to them.
But on the upside,
students really
did appreciate the feedback.
I mean, many of them went out of
their ways to thank me, to say,
oh, I'm so glad that
the department is
spending a lot of
time and energy
to give me additional feedback.
And many of them asked, OK,
what can I do practically now?
These are students that are
about to graduate, right,
in fourth years.
They said, only got a few months
before I go to graduate school.
What can I do?
Give me some advice.
So it's pretty clear that we
can't just give this assessment
and leave it at that.
We need to provide
students with opportunities
to bridge some of the gaps.
So another upside is that
the assessment can definitely
help students improve their
self-awareness as they progress
through the program.
And that's in
addition, of course,
to helping us improve teaching
and learning in our department.
So something that's
very interesting, here,
as part of the
interviews, is I asked
students, what is it that
made you think that you should
have gotten an A on this test?
And you know, not all of
them, but almost all of them,
they talk about their grades.
They said, well, it's too bad.
The only feedback that I get
from the program are my grades.
And I did pretty
good in my classes.
So that's why I would have
assumed that I would do well
on something like that.
So that was the source of their
disappointment, basically.
So as Logan mentioned,
when you think
about this, that's a pretty
backward way to design things,
right?
You're supposed to do
learning outcomes first,
and then from that
you're supposed
to build an assessment.
But we know it, practically,
just doesn't work that way.
Well, you should have seen
this in the faculty meeting--
the last one that we had.
I mean, people were
really engaged, right.
So that might be a good way
to trick faculty into starting
to talk about these things.
So the next steps here for
this coming year is, of course,
we need to design follow up
opportunities for students--
some seminar type courses.
We're bouncing ideas--
what we should do.
We need to revise and
validate the assessment.
And that will involve
a lot of interviews.
So I want to make sure that we
make this available to everyone
around the world, so they
can use this instrument.
And Karen Pearce, from
Institutional Research,
is already helping us, now,
with looking at correlations
with other institutional data.
For example, what courses
did students take?
What grades did they take?
And does that inform their
performance on this test?
And then, finally,
and not the least,
is that we need to develop
sustainable way to give that
to students.
So we want to give it at
the end of second year
and at the end of fourth year.
So students did
mention in interviews,
I wish I would have
had something like this
two years ago, because
I would have been
able to make some corrections.
It's too bad.
So giving it at the end of
second year-- that's easy
I would think not
just in physics,
but in most departments because
we have core courses, right.
Like this fall semester, I'm
teaching quantum mechanics
and every students have to
go through quantum mechanics.
So I'm going to
give it to students
at the end of the course.
That's easy.
But at the end of fourth year,
though, that's a serious issue.
This semester was really hard
to communicate with each student
individually, and schedule
time, and so forth.
[APPLAUSE]
Can you imagine a
world where that was
happening in every department?
All right.
So we're going to move on
to a different category.
And we're going to
go in this order.
And then at the end,
we're going to have
a little more depth about the
social innovation project.
So I love this project.
It's the project that
when everyone says to me,
what is curriculum mapping?
It's the one that I bring up
because it's just so clear.
Like, if you said,
across the university,
what are all of the
courses, all the ways,
that ethics is being taught?
It's probably taught in
every Harvard School.
How do we know where
the ethics courses are?
So the team-- which
you can see here--
Danielle Allen couldn't be here.
Jess Miner, Michael
Blauw, David Comer
Kidd they have been
working really hard.
And as I understand it, you
took inductive and deductive
approaches, both, to narrowing
in on the range of many words
that could be related
to ethics instruction.
And then you used that to
develop a weighted algorithm.
And then used that
weighted algorithm
to search all of the
syllabi, and then
to identify courses, survey
instructors, get their teaching
learning materials,
that then become
additional sources of data to
draw out the implicit learning
theories around ethics.
And to begin to think about
not just which courses,
but the pedagogical
approaches to teaching ethics.
And how to develop a community,
here, around those issues.
And then broaden that
community, outside of Harvard,
and think about
ethics instruction
out there in the world
and in other institutions.
So key constituents--
undergraduate and professional
students, faculty instructors,
and administrators.
That's the whole university.
[LAUGHING]
I think you could add alumni.
And I do think it does
have that applicability.
So look at this visual.
How many courses
were identified?
That's a lot of courses.
Then there is how many
were selected out of that,
and unique instructors.
And look at how many
survey responses they got.
This is already a community.
By next year, the goal is to
do another round of faculty
surveys, refine and
administer the pre-
and post-semester
student surveys--
so now learning from students--
and test and transfer the
methodology to other campuses.
And hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard--
build student-friendly tools
for identifying ethics courses
and learning opportunities.
What do student-friendly
tools look like?
We'll be getting
to that because I
think Jeffrey and others
in the curricle project
are also thinking about
student-friendly tools.
Identify strengths and gaps in
ethics education at Harvard,
promote discussion
and collaboration.
Similarly, Subu,
a faculty member
in the School of Public Health,
had another kind of question
that was crossing instruction
all across Harvard,
who's teaching applied
quantitative methods?
What are the applied statistics
courses that are being taught?
In social sciences,
by non-statisticians,
how did these courses compare?
How do students move through
the system to take courses
in applied statistics?
And people do move.
They don't just stick
in their school.
They move to other
schools to try
to get the methodological
training that they
feel that they need.
Graduate students are the
key constituency, here,
and then faculty.
By next year, have
a web resource
to facilitate optimal course
selection for students,
a synthesis-based deep dive of
what's being taught at Harvard,
with an aim to develop a
taxonomy of these courses.
That's a big goal.
It should be an interesting one.
And again, it will be drawing
on the data sources of syllabi
and course materials.
Subu or Judy might remember,
as we identified these courses,
reached out to
faculty, and said, hey,
could you send us our syllabi?
Because we couldn't
use syllabus tool
because it was not
just in the FAS.
Within an hour, you had
like hundreds of people,
or a lot of people writing.
There is a hunger
among the faculty
to be able to share their
resources with one another
and to build this
kind of community.
So one of the goals is just
making this meaningful faculty
connections and then providing
more course selection
support to students.
If you look at this
visual, you can
see the percentage of the
applied quantitative methods
by school, but we don't know
if this picture is accurate.
We really don't know.
I think this is a first stab.
And then we have to iterate
and learn to what degree this
might change over time.
So curricle is this amazing
intellectual project.
And when I first heard about
it, my jaw almost dropped.
I really couldn't believe
that this ambitious effort
was underway.
We have Jeffrey, Matthew Battles
couldn't be here, Sebastian, we
have Jessica, Kim,
here, from the team.
And you can see here, we've
got these two different--
they're both doing user testing
and still collecting data.
As I have thought
about this project,
there's two parts of it.
One is building a
curiosity-driven search
tool for students.
And the other is drawing
on really interesting
archival data about the
intellectual, curricular story
of Harvard over time.
I mean, going back the
hundreds of years of the things
that have been taught
at Harvard, to say,
how has Dante's
Inferno been taught
throughout Harvard's history?
And to develop these kind
of stories of a student's
progression, while
they were here,
that might get students to
think in different kinds of ways
than they usually do about
their own progression and path
through the curriculum.
So I think it's an ambitious
project because there's
a lot of data that might not
be digitized and easily put
into a format where you could
do that kind of deep work.
At the same time, it really
relates to a lot of the tools
that Dustin has been building.
And as we, in a more
straightforward way,
are building these tools
and increasing data sources,
we can pull it together
with the things
that Jeffrey and others
have been working on.
So research questions.
How might data visualization
reveal hidden connections
among courses of study?
How might we provide
students with meaningful data
in a user-friendly
format to support them
in course selection?
Using and adapting
historical curriculum data,
what stories can we tell about
intellectual and curricular
trends throughout
Harvard's history?
Students, faculty, department
chairs as key constituents.
Goals by June 2019.
One full academic year of public
prototype testing completed.
I think-- tell me
if this is right.
You're in prototype testing now?
Yeah.
Suite to visualization
micro narratives published,
and a mobile version in demo.
Hopes for curriculum mapping
at Harvard-- visualization
and data integration
will promote discovery
in course selection.
Visualizations can
show connections.
Now, how in the world--
I was looking at this
visual and was like, wait,
are these the schools
that tell the truth?
And these are the
schools that are--
and so I had to get
some clarification.
No, this tool allows you
to put in any two words
and then see which
schools have courses
that offer things related
to those words, overlapping.
And then, if you click on
one of those in the middle--
this is already an interface,
a tool that you can play with,
then you get to actually
see all the list of courses,
and the ways in which they're
talking about either truth
or lie.
All right.
DART.
I cannot do this
project justice.
I think you can't do it
justice in this format.
What you need to do is actually
play with this and have a demo.
You need to go and look at this.
There's a website.
And I should just say on the
little brochures we handed out,
there's a website you can go
and learn more information
about these tools.
Also, you can go and look
up DART in particular.
So imagine this
repository, where
you can put teaching
and learning
assets of any number
of sizes and shapes.
Right now, the
content has started
with HarvardX data, HarvardX
videos, and other assets that
are in HarvardX courses, as
well as Harvard YouTube video
assets.
But it could include any
kinds of teaching and learning
assets.
And then it's this really
powerful search tool.
So you search for a word
that you're interested in.
I think the demos I've
seen have been like moon.
And all of the things that
are related to moon come up.
And you can do a little
preview really quickly
of what these things look like.
Then, most magically,
you just say,
I want to put this
in my Canvas course.
Boom.
It's in your Canvas course,
and you can use it and share it
with your students.
So it is a work in progress.
Right now, as I understand
it, the more that Daniel
can get people to use
it and give feedback,
the more he can build new
attributes and new tools.
So you should talk with Daniel.
You should play with it, and
you should talk with Daniel.
And you should begin to see
what else he can do to help you
use this tool more over time.
By June 2019, cross
institutional content sharing
and more direct reuse
of Canvas resources.
So now, it's going
the other direction.
You have Canvas resources,
make it usable for everybody
to then put into
their Canvas courses.
This is what the
interface looks like.
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard--
provide data and
tools that allow
people to more directly
explore Harvard content.
We're going to now
hear from Brittany
for this last of our
curriculum mapping projects.
OK.
So hi, I'm Brittany Butler.
I'm the Executive Director
of the Social Innovation
and Change Initiative, which is
a relatively new initiative--
almost two years old
at the Kennedy School,
and an adjunct lecturer there.
And I'm representing
our team, the SICI team,
as well as my colleague,
Julie Battilana,
who's a professor
at both HBS and HKS.
So I have to say,
we're maybe the team
that joined this
group the latest,
and thus got to
benefit on riding
the coattails of the ethics
group, of the search tool,
of the fact that there
will very soon now
be this syllabus search
tool, because that's
sort of our next step.
And so thank you actually
to HILT for involving us.
We started out--
also, the mission
of the Social Innovation Change
Initiative at the Kennedy
School is to generate
new knowledge
and also to shape the
practice of innovation
with a social intent.
So not innovation to
make a profit, not
innovation for its
own sake, but to solve
a specific social problem.
And we entered into
this work essentially
because anecdotally
the student demand
was just like blasting up.
So our team was immediately
overwhelmed by the number
of students coming in and asking
for advice about which courses
they should take, asking about
the i-lab, asking about HIVE,
asking about all the
competitions on campus
and how they should be
navigating those things.
So this is really--
we entered with a set of
questions about the curricula,
but also a set of
questions about
extracurricular activities,
and how those overlap.
And the thing about social
innovation, unlike many
of the things that have
been described here,
but I think this is an
increasing trend also
in Higher Ed is it's not
actually a discipline.
It's-- at best, it's a phenomena
inside of certain disciplines,
and yet year after year, the
interest from students keeps
rising.
And as we talk to students
about what they want
and how they want to make
a difference in the world,
they say look there's this
specific social problem I care
about, and what's the
scope and sequence
that I should be
thinking through,
as I prepare myself to
go out there and do this.
And so we had terrible
answers for them.
And so-- like very basic level.
We just wanted to know--
is this the thing?
Yeah.
What courses are being taught?
What out of class innovation
experiences are offered?
And how do the perceptions
and experiences and demand
from the students
and external actors
about what's available
actually compare to the supply?
I mean, we just didn't
know anything about this.
And so we are very
much in this stage
and looking to go deeper soon.
So again, this is
where we started.
So there was a
report done in 2013
that gave us some
indication that 36%
of cross registration positions
across all the school--
so this is like a student
making an extra effort
to go into another school
because they perceive
that there's something
at another school that
isn't available in their own.
30% of those fall
into this category.
And many of the students
who made those petitions
were denied.
So we know there's
interest, just
locally, again, the
anecdotes were there.
And then on the supply
side, I mean, very spotty--
but the challenge
for us, also, was it
was difficult to
answer questions
for prospective students.
And at the Kennedy School,
and at the Business School,
in particular, we
were feeling the pain
of actually losing perspective
students because even though we
had this intuition
that, as a whole,
Harvard University offers
an incredible amount
on this front, we weren't
able to represent that well.
And that was scaring us.
And then yet at
the same time, you
know the students who were
pursuing this stuff would say,
like, I've already taken--
sort of that first quote
that you started with.
There is a lot of overlap
between these two classes,
and I really wish someone
could have given me
a heads up about that.
Because I don't feel like
I'm optimizing my time here.
So that's how we started.
But as we move forward,
some additional questions
surfaced that, again, I
think are important as folks
particularly think about
multi-disciplinary initiatives
or initiatives that aren't
clearly in a discipline,
but where the student
demand is high,
which is what is Harvard's
responsibility to get clear
about this stuff, given
that social innovation,
social change aren't traditional
academic disciplines.
And that's an open
question, but it's something
that, increasingly, every year
feels like we need to answer.
And what can and
should be accomplished
through the curricular
versus the co-curricular?
So the Social Innovation
and Change Initiative
actually runs a
fellowship program.
It's a co-curricular program for
15 select students every year
who are working on advancing
a project that they plan
to continue when they graduate.
They can get up to $30,000
to advance those projects
when they finish.
But is that the only
experience that they should
be getting here in the school?
And how does that
relate to what's
happening in the classroom?
So very much along
the lines of what's
going on with the research stuff
and how much is that shaping
students' experience here?
It's something we want
to understand better.
And then what opportunities
are we missing?
And it just seems like there's
a lot of low-hanging fruit that
we don't have--
we don't really
understand again.
So this is just a
quick sense of how
we approached putting our
arms around this space
and even just defining
what we're talking about.
Lucas, you spent a
lot of time on this.
So just a sample--
this is just a sample.
There are 521 uni courses, OK,
so that's on the next slide.
But this is just a sample.
And look at the range.
Innovators Practice Finding
Building Leading Good Ideas,
Applied Music Activism,
Thermal Tectonics
for the Next Billion People,
Designing for the Just City,
Innovative Approaches to Teacher
Prep, Innovation and Ministry.
I mean, these are all
processes that certainly aren't
100% overlapping, but where
you can really quickly come
to understand that you need to
be able to define the problem,
right.
There's a set of
competencies, here,
that each of these
students need to get.
You need to understand the
root causes of those problems.
You need to be able
to iterate and think
in an iterative learning way
about potential solutions
and make selections
about those solutions.
And you need to understand your
own role as a social change
maker.
And so despite the
fact that they're
all across different
schools, and potentially
different in many ways, there's
actually a lot of similarities.
And that's what we wanted
to start to understand.
This is a set of keywords.
So we followed, again, on the
coattails of the ethics folks
and did this iterative process
of looking for keywords
in the course descriptions.
We would have loved to have
been able to drill down
to the level of the
syllabi, because we suspect
that when we talk about
the competencies required
to be an effective
social innovator,
it might be happening
at that syllabus level.
And when we get there,
we will do that.
But in the meantime,
it just gives you
a sense of the range of search
terms that came up for us.
And then we would feed
those back in to the system
until we came to this 521.
And so yeah, for
next year, I mean,
in terms of what
kind of resources
can we use to support
students and faculty
in creating a community
and finding their way--
we've been thinking about
a compendium of curricula.
We think that just would be an
interesting contribution, also,
beyond Harvard.
And that that would then draw
folks into the conversation,
broadly.
Oh, this is our
big takeaway, which
is that pretty much every single
school is offering courses
on this front.
I mean, and it's really
pretty well distributed.
There's an other
group, here, that
represents a couple
of the schools,
but, again, this, just like
Erin said about the other,
this is our first
cut at a snapshot.
We're still trying to figure
out even what the bounds are.
And so a step for us--
next step for us will
also be connecting
with relevant faculty.
Faculty are interested
in this work,
particularly faculty who have an
experiential learning pedagogy.
They seem to be
very drawn to this.
And ask them for
reactions to the set
of courses we've surfaced.
And then eventually just
make recommendations
to improve the student pathway
for making social impact.
I mean, many of them
come here and say
that's why they're
getting an education, now.
And so how can we prepare
them to do that well?
And then hopes-- yeah, I
mean, just that, again,
the multi-disciplinary
learning journey in particular
could be a little
easier for students.
Right now, we're very siloed.
I think we all know that.
And they feel it the most.
And then creating connection
between faculty and students
who would benefit from
working with each other.
I mean, even on
this project, I feel
like I've connected with
some of you who might not
have identified as falling
into social innovation,
but when we get down
to the nitty gritty,
I think we're actually
grappling with a lot
of similar questions.
And this idea of
developing a one Harvard
ecosystem, especially
when resources
are distributed across school.
So the Kennedy School cannot
own social innovation.
And we know that.
But Harvard as a
whole, really could
be a dominant player in this
space, if we could coordinate.
So there are certain topics
where no department, no school
is going to be able to
really shape a field,
but together we might be
able to do quite a bit.
So that's where I'm at.